denise nevada health care advocates are
rallying in downtown las vegas at the
federal courthouse that is where madison
kimbrough joins us live in madison
they're calling for federal lawmakers
and the biden harris administration to
protect the rights to obtain an abortion
madison again live at that rally
as you can see behind me there are a
bunch of people here probably a hundred
plus showed up for the band off my body
rally it started an hour ago now it's
unclear how much longer it will last out
here on las vegas boulevard near clark
but it looks like it may be wrapping up
soon what started as a couple dozen
people has definitely increased over the
past hour it's been a peaceful with many
coming with signs there have been an
influx with megaphones t-shirts and
flags victoria ruiz organized the event
she is with planned parenthood she says
hosting a rally tonight is a must at
this point
it's just
outrageous that what's happening now
right that
the precedent that was sent under the
landmark decision of roe v wade is not
being respected and so really today it's
about
being in solidarity as a community
hearing from folks who will be you know
directly impacted by this decision
now as you can see tons of people are
still out here you can see flags you can
see signs a megaphone example
started around five o'clock and it
honestly continues to grow earlier i
thought it was dying down but now i'm
seeing more people coming so there's a
good possibility that this could last
throughout the next hour initially we
thought that there were people for both
sides of the issue but we've only seen
those who support women's rights to
choose here at this rally tonight we of
course bring you live coverage coming up
at 11 p.m on this story reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now